hello back to
8701 um so in this section we'll talk
about
relativistic kinematics um but let me
start by saying that
one of my favorite classes here at mit
is a class called age
20 special relativity where
we teach students about special
relativity of course but einstein
and paradoxes and it's one of my
favorite classes
and in that class um there's a component
on particle physics
which has to do with just using
relativistic kinematics in order to
understand
how to create antimatter how to
you know collide beams how we can
analyze the case
and in this introductory section we want
to do a very similar thing
um i trust that you all had some sort of
class introduction of
special relativity some of you may be
general relativity
what we want to do here is review this
content very
briefly but then more use it in a number
of examples
so in particle physics nuclear physics
we often deal with particles which
travel
close to the speed of light the photon
travels at the speed of light
we typically define the velocity as v
over c
in natural unit better beta is the
velocity
gamma is defined by one over square root
one minus
the velocity squared beta is always
smaller or equal to one smaller for mass
massive particles
and gamma is always equal or greater
than one
the total energy of a particle with zero
mass
non-sorry with non-zero mass is then
given by
gamma times m c square
um and the momentum is given by gamma
times mv or
gamma times m beta
the total energy squared of a particle
and we are considering one massive
particular one particle
it's given by energy squared equal
momentum squared plus mass squared
um if you now consider a particle with
zero mass you see that the energy and
the momentum are equal
if you consider particular at rest
meaning the momentum is zero
you see that the energy is equal to the
mass so you get einstein's famous
formula
the energy is equal e equal on the c
square the energy is equal to the mass
or there is an equivalence between those
two
what we want to fully under understand
and control our lawrence transformations
uh here shown for the example that we
have a boost or a transformation in x
direction
so you see that energy momentum
transform like
time and space um and you just i really
encourage you to just review this
um in more general cases but you can
always when you have
a boost in one direction just do a
rotation and get to this more simplified
case
so here's the first example i would like
you to actually go through
um the lawrence transformation here i
decided to use the z direction
just to change things up a little bit
and the velocity of the boosted frame
is vb so we want to calculate
the quantity m square c squared in the
transform
frame and what you will find if you
actually do the calculation and the
solutions are in the
backup slides is that that quantity
doesn't change under learn's
transformation it is invariant
and we talk about an invariant mass in
this context
so now in particle physics we often have
the case that we are not
considering considering just one
particle and want to describe this one
particle or measure it
but often the case of particles or
multiple particles which are involved in
a reaction
so we can look at the total energy just
the sum of the energy of all particles
the total momentum
the sum of the momentum of all particles
and those two quantities are always
conserved
they are not invariant so be aware of
the distinction between
conserved properties and invariant
properties
in variant here means you know we
perform a transformation
like the lawrence transformation and the
property doesn't change
conserved here means we have a reaction
and in that reaction the property is not
changing
those are two different distinct things
so now you can
you look at the invariant property or
the one which is conserved
in in this collision which is this this
mass term or
mass square term the total mass we need
to define this
total mass as equal to the energy square
minus the momentum square
and then we can consider the two cases
of a laboratory frame
and the so-called center of mass frame
so in the laboratory frame
we have a particle it's moving now we
observe this particle and then it decays
into in this example three water
particles
in the center of mass frame in this
example we put ourselves
into the rest frame of the particle we
are interested in
and in that frame then three particles
emerge
come and we can describe the three
particles so momenta between the three
daughter particles are not going to be
the same but
because this total mass
is an invariant property it's the same
in both frames
and it's equal to the mass of the parent
particle which we discard
so when you measure the energy and
momentum of the daughter particles
you can infer in any frame the mass of
the
parent particle by calculating the total
mass
and so you can infer from those
measurements
the identity of the mother particle
and that's for example how we discover
the higgs boson we measure
the higgs boson decay into a pair of
photons
and then we calculate the mass of those
two photons in our laboratory frame
and that mass n is equal to the higgs
[Music]
moss
so now here we want to compare or look
into those two cases a little bit more
the first case is a case where we have a
particle one
colliding with a particle two where the
particle two is at rest
particle 1 has a certain energy e1 and
the second example this is called a
fixed target experiment so
the second particle is fixed the first
one is colliding
the second example is the one where we
have two particles
and both have energies and we bring them
to collision
often the two particles in nature like
two protons
on electron and positron and the
energies of the beams are the same
but this doesn't have to be the case
later in the class we'll
look at heavy iron collision so the
collision of heavy ions like lead
is a proton and here the masses are
different and the energy of the
particles can be different
all right and here's another exercise
now so we want to actually create a z
boson
which has a mass of about 191 gev
note i dropped the c square one over c
square here
and you want to produce this party by
colliding a positron with an electron
so this has happened at lab at cern in
the late 80s and 90s
the center of mass energy often also
called
square root s is equal to 91 gev
so that's the energy we need in order to
produce this new particle
the mass of the electron and the
positron are
511 kav or 0.511 mav
so the energy needed is 45 gb
45.5 geb however
that was the you know setup at lab where
you have two beams colliding so we have
this
you know center of mass energy being
given by the energy directly given
approximately by the energy of the two
b's
so now imagine somebody would have
proposed a fixed target experiment
where you have stationary electrons for
example
electrons in atoms you know just a gas
of some sorts
and then you have produced positrons in
a beam
accelerate them and bring them into
collision so the question here now is
how large does the do you need an energy
of this positron beam
how large does it have to be in order to
produce a zebra
so again this is something i would like
you to actually
explore and just write down solutions
for this example also in the backup
so now you know there is a number of
interesting examples just coming from e
equal and z squared
and from being able to use and they can
be answered
by be able to use loans transformation
and so now here i give you just a set of
examples and
um you know you should work on them on
your own time maybe we'll touch on them
in presentation
the first one is rather straightforward
um again we're talking about lab at cern
um you know after the z-bosons were
produced
one was trying to go to high energy to
find some new physics some new particle
uh for example the higgs boson the
exposure might be produced
by a process which is called higgs
schwalms process we will look at this
later
so we have an electron and a positron
colliding to
virtual the boson so that is a z boson
which is heavier than 91gb
you'll see later how that's possible but
then that virtual z-boson can
radiate a higgs boson so that's why it's
called extra long like the german word
for radiation stralong
process and so
electrons and positrons were accelerated
to 100 gv each
center of mass energy 200 gev what was
the gamma factor for those electrons
um another question which is quite
exciting is how much energy do you need
in order to split
a proton and a neutron which is a bound
state it's called a deuteron
and it's a fundamentally important
particle in the evolution of our
universe
in a sense that in order to generate
higher mass or higher proton number
elements
neutron is rather important than this
and so just by knowing
the mass of the proton the mass of the
neutron and the mass of the deuteron
we can now calculate um how much energy
is in the bind it was
what is the binding energy between those
particles
we'll talk a lot about models to
calculate binding energy when we talk
about
nuclear physics but here just from the
kinematics you can and from e equal mc
square you can calculate
how much energy needs to be in this
binded or compound state
um from atomic physics you might
remember or know that
particles can excited particles can emit
photons
and so now you have a particle you know
it goes
it de-excites it radiates a photon what
happens now to the photon imagine this
is happening in a big gas
or in some solid state can the photon be
reabsorbed by the same medium
or even by the same by the same particle
it's not a trivial question but what is
the condition
under which so for example imagine you
have a gas there's an excited particle
in it
it emits a photon and so now the photon
sees the rest of the gas
can that rest of the gas absorbs the
photon
interesting question it's not trivial um
another interesting question i think is
you know
you're trying to produce new forms of
matter um
like you just produced the z boson but
you can also produce
anti-protons so what is the minimal
energy
in a proton on a fixed target experiment
so again you have a target of protons on
in some form you shoot a proton against
this target
and you try to produce an antiproton
so that means that you have to produce
in this collision you have two protons
in the initial state
you have to have a proton a proton
another proton and an antiproton in your
final state
um but how much energy is needed for the
proton beam in order to succeed with
this collision
my accounting is incorrect here so this
should be five but okay fine
um the case so i assume a pioneer decays
at rest so pion is at rest
we looked at a pion that's a compound
state a meson
out of an up quark and a down quark and
it might decay
an electron on the positron whatever
you know the dynamics is in this the
case um if you just look at the
kinematics of this
how fast are the decay products in order
to calculate that you need to look up
the iron mass
electron mass we just discussed and the
positron has the same mass
so how fast are electron and positron
coming out of a pi indicator
assume that the pioneer is at rest then
you can
use momentum conservation and calculate
the speed
of the fault of the electrons and
positrons
um again one of those minimal energy
proton colliding experiments
very similar setup but here we try to
produce
a proton a neutron and the pion out of
port important collision
and then the last one is the so-called
compton effect where you have a photon
which scatters off
an electron target and so you have a
incoming photon an electron is in rest
and then you look at the scattered
photon angle
scattered electron angle and in that
collision the energy of the photon is
going to change
so the energy of the photon is h times
nu or
h over lambda the wavelength and so the
question is
how does the wavelength of the photon
change in this kind of collision
so those are just examples in how you
can use
relativistic kinematics in order to
calculate very important aspects of
collisions in particle physics
without any understanding at this point
of
the underlying dynamics the underlying
forces the underlying
you know conservation laws
and so on so in later in this class we
discuss
what is the likelihood of a pioneer to
decay into an electron positron
and why that is actually not that likely
um
and also you know the collision rates
lifetimes of particles but here we are
just looking at the kinematic
of those processes and calculate you
know how much energy is involved
and for the momentum of resulting
particles
so i'll stop here if you scroll down
on the slides you find solutions to two
of the problems
and we'll discuss them in recitation